- Oh hell yeah, man, football is back—
Oh hell no, Antonio.
- THIS IS CLEARLY NOT TO CODE—
- IF I CAN'T LIVE HERE,
I'M LEAVING GRIDIRON—
- Thanks so much, guys!
My leg’s been trapped under
this vending machine all summer!
- HEY GUYS,
THERE’S BEEN ANOTHER ANTONIO BROWN THING!
- Woah!
- Gotta check that out!
- Haha, that’s OK!
Wait.
Maybe it’s NOT OK...
- Alright, I played nice.
I moved houses.
- A.B., you clearly just painted your old Steelers house.
- IF A.B. WANTS TO BUILD ON A CLIFF,
LET HIM BUILD ON A CLIFF.
- I’M SICK OF A.B.
Up Next:
The Top ONE THOUSAND A.B. Offseason Moments.
- Not everyone can be besties like Coach and I!
- PLEASE HELP!
AARON HURT MY LEG AND HE SAID HE’LL DO IT AGAIN—
- Does anyone even care I’m training on a beach again?
- A.B.! A.B.!
- Antonio!
- ENOUGH.
I can’t do this anymore
I’m leaving lol.
- NO!
- You can do that?
- Remember:
You can always find me in the throw of a football….
WEEEEE!!!!!
- Was Andrew Luck real or just a dream we all had?
- He was real.
He was damn real.
- AHHH!
Subscribe to this channel by double-doinking below.
I mean double-clicking.
Double-kick below—
WHO BROUGHT UP KICKING?
-Uh, you did, Coach.
No I doinkn’t.
I mean, I DIDN’T.
I DOUBLE DOINK DIDN’T.
I’M OVER THE DOUBLE DOINK.